[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous video uh we had
discussed the problem of a plate with a
circular hole in it
under uniaxial tensile loading and we
had mentioned how that
problem is a precursor to
an entire field of mechanics called
fracture mechanics in much the same way
in today's lecture also we are going to
discuss a very special
uh problem called the flumant problem
which will again be a precursor
to another uh another field of mechanics
called contact mechanics
so let me write that down here contact
mechanics
now this is a tremendously important
area of research of a professional
engineering application because you
understand that uh
especially within the context of
mechanical engineering
uh you have uh such a multitude of
applications
where two bodies are coming into contact
with each other
with the resultant stresses the
various deformations coming into the
picture and all of that
falls under the broad purview of this
contact mechanics going beyond
mechanical engineering also
uh if we go into the field of uh
of soil mechanics of geophysical
sciences of civil engineering
there also you will find that this
flammant problem
is like the introductory problem to uh
to an entire
field of study where
people do various uh interesting and
important
professionally important things related
to structures as they stand on ground
uh various loadings taking place on uh
on the earth etc etc so with this kind
of
motivation let me write that down also
here so this kind of a problem has
applications in geophysical sciences uh
civil engineering
etc etc okay so
so what is this problem what have i
depicted here so this horizontal line
this horizontal straight line that i
have drawn
that basically uh you can think of it
like
uh like the boundary of a half space
so what i mean by a half space is that
the entire portion which is beneath
it it could be above it also but in this
particular case it is beneath it so the
entire
portion which is beneath it that is
actually the solid material okay i'm not
drawing it by hash but
because it will unnecessarily clutter
the diagram i have to draw other things
also here
uh so you understand that this is the
half space region okay so uh
so so you can imagine that uh
so if if there is if there had been no
boundary here
if this had been all one continuum so
that would have been the
infinite full space and because there is
the
the solid material present only beneath
it that is why this is the infinite half
space
okay uh now on this half space
okay so we are looking at it from
sideways
okay so on this half space we have this
kind
of load okay
and the question that we ask ourselves
is that as a result of this load what is
the stress distribution
in this in this entire half space
region okay and that's a very important
question
so you can imagine that maybe some kind
of pole
is standing here having some weight or
some building is standing here on the
ground
having some weight so what will be the
stresses generated in the ground
beneath it furthermore uh closer home to
mechanical engineering
suppose uh you have some kind of
indenter acting on a
on a on a flat surface which has
some depth
and maybe the dimensions and the loading
of uh
of that indenter is such that the thick
and the thickness of the of the of the
material also
is also such that it can for all
practical purposes be considered to be
some sort of a half space
or infinite half space then also this is
a good enough
model for that situation uh
you also note that this is just like the
two-dimensional projection of the actual
situation
so you can think of it that
so maybe i can just clarify the
three-dimensional picture so suppose
i have this kind of the ground or some
surface
and there is material beneath it
there is material beneath it going to
infinity
okay like this
and it is on this surface that i have
this distribution like a line loading
okay so this is like a line loading
[Music]
and this goes off to infinity here this
goes obtainability here just like the
surface also goes off to infinity here
goes up to infinity here
so when you look at it from this side
this entire picture
will look like this okay so this is the
part
the bottom is the part where i have
drawn those kinds of
okay so these these vertical lines the
correspond here
okay
it's like that all right uh i won't
clutter the diagram any more than this
now how do we address the problem of
finding the
stresses uh in this region so for that
what we'll do is we will from the very
beginning
exploit the symmetry of the situation so
suppose you considered
that
that our x axis is oriented like this
okay suppose your x axis is oriented
like this
then to the right of this and to the
left of this
okay then that situation is perfectly
symmetric
and we are going to exploit this so how
are we going to exploit this
so uh you understand that although i
have written it like an
x and what i can do
is i can think
i can imagine that
i can imagine that if i consider a
semicircular
arc like this okay semicircular arc like
this
centered at the very origin from which
the x is
originating then all around this
arc okay because of the entire symmetry
of the situation
the stress distribution is going to be
the same okay
[Music]
well it is not so simple like that okay
it is it is
there there will be some variation along
this
but whatever it is suppose you consider
a point here
maybe at a certain angle theta from this
x-axis
if you consider the same a corresponding
point on this side
at the same angle theta from this x axis
the situation here
and the situation here is going to be
the same but of course there is going to
be variation
all along this r okay
so ah we are uh uh
now in a position to actually uh
utilize our uh our machinery
of uh of solution of the of the 2d
elasticity solution in polar coordinates
in this kind of a setup okay so the
thing will be clear
only when we do the actual solution and
talking about the solution for this
particular very special problem
we have to proceed in a special way
which will be somewhat different from
the usual way we have been proceeding
till now
so so what are we basically trying to do
here
you see if i have to actually satisfy
the the force balance here so to speak
then the condition the fundamental
condition that i need to satisfy
is something like this
so this is the starting point of our
whole solution okay
we are not we are as i as i just
mentioned
we have to proceed in a slightly
different fashion
here so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to consider
[Music]
a little uh elemental arc
of rd theta so uh let's say that
this is theta so this theta
goes from minus pi by 2 to pi by 2 here
okay in order to cover this entire arc
and
[Music]
this little bit here
that is my uh rd theta
where of course you note that this
portion here
is the r okay
so if we consider a bigger arc that
r is going to change all right so this
is the generic situation
now in this situation the force balance
condition that has to be maintained
can be written in an integration or an
in or in an integrated fashion in this
way
so you understand like this suppose we
isolate this
semicircular zone okay suppose we
isolate this semicircular zone
then the only force that we are
currently seeing
is this vertically downward force p
okay so how is this force p going to be
balanced
it is going to be balanced because of
the traction conditions here
and those traction conditions you can
understand that
suppose you consider this little arc
itself so we'll have
some kind of the sigma rr here okay
so that's sigma rr
that
that sigma r r when it is multiplied
by the r d theta
it is going to give me and of course you
understand that there is
uh a hidden unit length into the plane
of the screen but i'm not going to write
that
so sigma r r into r d theta it gives
me the force in the radial direction
okay it gives me the force in this
radial direction
but that is not what i want i want the
component of that force
in the vertical direction and what is
the component of that force in the
vertical direction
i have to multiply this thing by cos
theta
now uh we don't have to worry about the
the the horizontal component because as
i already mentioned
when you consider the corresponding
point
or the corresponding or a corresponding
element like this
on on this side of the x-axis
that will have a force like this and
that horizontal component will be
in this opposite direction to what it is
present here so
this force here is like this
that force here would be like that and
the horizontal component
okay so the horizontal component here
would be balanced or negated by this
however the vertical component would
still be
but still have to be considered because
both of them are in the same direction
so as we go from minus pi
by 2 to pi by 2 as theta goes from minus
pi by 2 to pi by 2
it is the vertical component which is
getting
which is getting cumulatively added up
okay so all that you have to do
is take this integration from minus pi
by 2
to pi by 2
and so this is
plus p is equal to
0 right
so now
[Music]
what we can say from here is uh
is that this entire thing is just going
to be equal to minus p so we can write
that down alternatively
okay so
so this is just going to be equal to
minus
b okay so this is the beginning
of our arguments
we are not going to directly talk about
the air stress function right away
rather we are going to consider this
sigma rr itself
right now we don't know what the sigma
rr is
okay so how can we uh how can we find it
out
so this is like a little bit of
detective work that we have to do here
you see this entire integration
is with respect to theta okay
so whatever we do here after the
integration has been done
and after the proper limits have been
put
the result of this integration will be
such
that the answer of this integration will
not involve
any theta dependence
okay so uh
on the right hand side we see that very
nicely
there is no theta dependence so at least
that part is
consistent but on the left hand side
apparently there is some kind of a r
dependence
but that r dependence is not present on
the right hand side
so what to do we have to somehow do
something such that this r dependence
this very
inconvenient looking uh our dependence
on the left hand side
that has to go away such that it becomes
whatever is there on the left hand side
that becomes equal to the right hand
side okay because this right hand side
is a given constant
it simply does not depend on r it does
not depend on theta
the theta that the independence of theta
has been taken care of by the
integration itself
but the independence of r how do we take
care of that that is the question
so this is not actually a very hard
question what we can do is
we can think of it like this that
suppose
if sigma rr is
of this particular form suppose
it is of the form that in the numerator
there is some function of theta
we currently don't know what that is if
we knew it
our half our job would be done but right
now we don't know about it
so let's keep it like this some unknown
function of theta but a pure function of
theta
and in the denominator there is a r
so what is the motivation motivation is
that the moment we do this
we we place this form here this r is
going to get cancelled with this r
okay so when that happens
automatically the answer that we get
will be independent of i and certainly
independent of theta
okay so this is our first uh
our first achievement as detective work
okay now what to do because till now you
see we have not talked about the ad
stress function and unless we talk about
the idea stress function how can we
solve the 2d elasticity problem so so we
do have to
talk about the air stress function so we
are we are going to
approach this in a clever fashion what
we will do is
we'll take a look we'll take a relook at
the form
the general form of the sigma rr as it
depends
on a general addie stress function phi
okay
so we go to our jupiter notebook i have
already fired up a new file here
let me import this
polar utilities first
all right now let me first define a
general
a very general uh eddy stress function
like this
okay please note that this was this is
not
by default uh defined in
uh in the polar utilities package so i
have to actually do it
the r and theta the r theta symbols are
very much defined
in the polar utilities package so i can
i can immediately use that without
without
defining it separately in this file
okay so
[Music]
all right so let me just check what phi
is so there it is
a very generic function phi now
what i will do is i'll just take a look
at the form of the sigma rr
as it depends on this phi this sigma
underscore
rr is a function definition already
defined in this polar utilities package
i'm just calling it here i am calling it
here
and making it operate on this generic
function
file i have just defined
so you see this is the font okay
so let me utilize this form this 1 by r
del phi del r plus 1 by r square del
square 5 del theta square let me utilize
this thing
here okay
1 by r del phi
del r plus 1 by
r square del square phi
del theta square now this thing
this sigma r r it has to be
as we have just found out it has to be
of this particular form
which means that this 1 by r gets
cancelled
we are left with this
now see this is a very very interesting
situation
what do we have here so this is del phi
del r
okay and there is a 1 by r del square by
del theta square
fine now
what could be the possible form of this
phi
such that when we differentiate this phi
with respect to
r that our dependence in it goes away
this is the question we want to answer
because you see on the right hand side
we have a function
which is purely dependent on theta
that can only happen when this term
like del phi del r from that
the r dependence completely goes away
after this differentiation with respect
to r
here also you note that if we have
such a phi okay
so we need to have certified
that from this partial derivative with
respect to theta
automatically what should happen is that
whatever r dependence comes out
that has to be negated by this one by r
so the consideration of both these facts
or the clues
associated with both these terms it
tells us
that there is only one possibility here
so you think about it a little bit
there is only one possibility here and
that possibility
is that phi must be of the form r
into some function of theta
so we call that g so if phi is
r times g theta then what is going to
happen
is that when you differentiate this phi
with respect to r
this r goes away it remains this g theta
remains
and when you differentiate this phi with
respect to theta
twice all right we have this
d square uh g d theta square
but this r dependence it comes out and
it gets cancelled with this one by r
so overall on the left hand side we have
a pure dependence on theta
which is consistent with the fact that
on the right hand side also
we have a pure dependence on theta so
this is our second major achievement
in our detective work okay so
and this is actually the starting point
of
uh of the work that we can do in our
jupiter notebook
so we go back to that we go back to our
jupiter notebook
and instead of this generic uh this
generally defined phi
we specialize it to the particular form
that we really want okay so first of all
of course we have to define this
[Music]
g
ah so this is
r into g
all right now
uh as we have done so many times earlier
our first job will be to actually
satisfy the polar bear harmonic equation
okay so let's set up
an equation the polar bear harmonic
equation like this
so we put a comma and
again as we have done uh earlier on the
left hand side of the comma
we will will utilize our polar by
harmonic definition
or function definition as we have
already done that
in the in the polar utilities package
and on the right hand side we have zero
okay so this is our bioharmonic equation
let us display this
[Music]
so you see it is such a nice thing
if you had actually done this by hand
this
1 by r cube on the left hand side which
is common in all the terms
that you would have simply cut out and
all that would have remained is just
this
is this nice ordinary differential
equation
containing the various derivatives of
g theta and of course this g theta term
itself
okay so now uh our immediate
job will be to solve for this g theta
okay that's exactly what we are going to
do so
let's try to solve this thing so this is
a simple differential equation and we
use the desolve command to
solve this let's see if this
gives us any solution
and see how nicely it is giving us it is
so you don't even have to worry about
manually cutting out this
r cube it has already taken care of it
itself okay
so if you if you if you had proceeded so
maybe
what you could have proceeded by hand
maybe what you could have done
is to write this this
g theta as something like
ah so if i go back here
maybe i go to a new page so for the
g theta differential equation uh
so this is our d4 g theta d theta four
d four
plus twice d square g
d theta square plus g
is equal to 0 okay so what you could
have possibly done
is to take something like g is equal to
maybe
theta to the power m something like that
or sorry
you could have taken that to be
something like
e to the power m theta
and if you had substituted it here then
uh you could have
obtained a nice uh algebraic
uh equation involving m so
it's actually very easy to do uh
so you'll get an m4 out of this you'll
get a
m square out of this and this is going
to be simply 1
and you can you can obtain the the
solutions
of m easily from there so you are going
to obtain actually
four different solutions of m uh and
you can you can go back and write down
uh
the general solution out of that so
that's exactly what has been done for us
in
in same pie the solution is given to us
now what we'll do is we will
we will rewrite this solution uh in a
slightly different fashion
okay so what we'll do is you see there
are four different constants here c1 c2
c3 and c4
and all of these terms have been written
in terms of this e to the power i theta
minus id and that's fine that that's
exactly the
thing that you would obtain by hand but
what i would like to do is to use the
uh use the expansion of e to the power i
theta is cos theta plus i sine theta
okay uh and and and rewrite
the solution for g theta in terms of cos
theta and sine theta so if we do that
okay so what we get is let me first
define four new constants abcd uh
and let me define a g nu
in this fashion so a into cos
into cos theta plus b
into theta into
cos theta
plus c into sine theta
plus d into theta into
sine theta
[Music]
so that's the solution that i uh that i
want to
uh there's a solution form that i want
to
deal with okay now and you can actually
easily see this if you if you come back
here
uh so
so c 1 plus c 2 theta e to the power
minus i theta
so terms like that so c 1 plus c
to theta e to the power minus i theta
so sorry here
and c3 plus c4
theta
e to the power i theta what you can do
is
this one you can expand like cos theta
minus i sine theta
[Music]
cos theta minus i sine theta
and this one you can expand like cos
theta
plus i sine theta
and if you multiply out the terms you
will you will end up
and and algebraically simplify it you
will end up with a form like this
okay okay so now
uh we want to have
a new file okay so
this is what we want
and let me display this uh this this
this
this new solution form that we have
obtained after solving the by harmonic
equation
uh using the ipython display style uh
so
so as you have done so many times
earlier
all right so that's what i uh want now
so
please note that there is an r present
here okay
so now with this solution form for phi
i want to take a look at what are the
solution or what are the
forms for the various stress components
so let me see that quickly
[Music]
and again i use my ipython display style
i quickly copy paste this to reduce the
typing
let me finish that up quickly
that is sigma r theta
all right so you see the sigma theta
theta is identically zero the sigma r
theta is also equal to 0
but the sigma rr is something okay and
we have to do a little bit of detective
work
associated with this also okay
so let's get back to our writing app and
write this form
okay minus 2b sine theta by r plus 2d
cos theta by r
very nice let me write this down
so so sigma rr
is equal to let me just take a look
minus 2b sine theta by r
minus 2p
sine theta by r
plus twice d cos
theta by r right
and let me quickly take a look back at
what i had done in the previous page
so see at the very beginning of our
discussions
we had been saying that no matter what
we end up with
the situation must be perfectly
symmetric about this
x-axis that was our
first clue okay we have not yet utilized
that
that thing now when we are saying
that uh this
whatever we are getting as our answer as
our stress distribution that must be
symmetric about this x-axis
it basically means that
this particular form this very very
starting
form that we had arrived at as a result
of our first major achievement of our
detective work
so here the theta dependence
captured through this or represented
through this h theta
it must be such that it must be
symmetric about this theta equal to zero
okay so you know that theta equal to
zero it coincides with this
x axis so so what we basically want to
say is that
h theta must be symmetric about theta
equal to zero
fine now uh so see
our r does not contribute to the
symmetry or asymmetry of it
okay the only symmetry question arises
with this h theta dependence
so what we are saying is that sigma r r
should be such that the theta dependence
should be symmetric about
theta equal to zero and now in the next
page we have just seen from jupiter
notebook
that we are arriving at this at this
solution form after the
after the solution of the polar bear
harmonic equation
now use now we set ourselves the
question
uh like what what are the
uh what are the symmetricities
associated with these individual terms
so first we check for this cos theta
term now cos
theta is very much symmetric about
theta equal to zero so this is
absolutely fine
okay with our fundamental requirement
that the sigma rr
should be such that it must be symmetric
about theta equal to 0
so cos theta being symmetric about theta
equal to 0
satisfies that
that clue but what about the sine theta
okay so sine theta is not symmetric
about
theta equal to zero and you can quickly
see here so if we just plot
this the the theta okay
so we know that our our theta plot will
be something like this okay where this
is 0
this is pi this is twice pi
and if you continue it like this it will
be like it will be going like that
so you see about the 0 the sign
is not symmetric rather it is
anti-symmetric
so this is our sine theta plot
okay so on this axis is theta
on the other hand if we consider uh
if we consider our cos theta
okay our cos theta will be something
like this
so this is again 0 this is pi and this
is
uh so i have to complete this here
sorry i just had a brain freeze
so it's like this
i think i made a mistake
let me be consistent with this
so at 0 cos theta is 1
add pi by 2
at pi by 2 it is 0
at pi it is minus 1 then it goes up
like that and again at
theta equal to twice phi we have this
so
we have this thing but the important
point to note here
is that it should be like this
on this side also okay so what is
basically happening here is that
this cos theta is symmetric about the
zero axis
that's that's the important point here
so this term
has to be deleted this term has to
remain and this term can be deleted
so this term has to be deleted this term
has to be kept which means
that b must be equal to zero
so that is that is the that is the
latest achievement
in our series of detective works so if
you go back to our jupiter notebook
what we can do is for our sigma rr
[Music]
we can substitute b as 0
and
we have this new form for sigma rr
now our job is practically complete all
that we have to do
is to find out the appropriate
appropriate value or the appropriate
solution
for this unknown constant d and what is
the clue that is left in our hand
if we go back to our writing app you
will see
that our job is basically done here
because all that you could do is to
satisfy
this condition here okay this
integration condition we have to satisfy
if we satisfy that this is one equation
standing
which has not yet been properly utilized
we have used it to obtain some ideas
about the solution forms but we have not
really utilized this
equation and that's exactly what we are
going to do so
in in previous problems uh what we had
done in
terms of boundary conditions here
so this is like the counter part of that
boundary condition it note that this is
not really a boundary condition
okay but this is like an indirect form
of that
boundary condition but this is uh
definitely an equation and we have to
satisfy this and please note that it is
through this condition
that the the influence of this external
loading is also appearing in our in our
problem solution
so if we go back to our uh if we go back
to our jupyter notebook
we have to implement this uh this this
solution
through a uh to an equation okay
so what we do is
we write this integration command
here we have sigma r now this has to be
multiplied by r
and it has to be multiplied by cos theta
and note this integration should be such
that
theta goes from minus pi
by 2 to
pi by 2 okay so
so this thing that we have here this
this is the lower limit
and this here is the upper limit
okay now this is just the left hand side
okay so this is the left hand side the
right hand side
of our equation is just the minus p but
note that we have not yet defined p so
we could
quickly do that
right and we set up our equation very
nicely like this
as we have done so many times earlier
okay so this is the equation that we
need to solve
let us just display this equation
okay before we solve it let's display
this equation
so you see this is such a simple
equation pi d is equal to minus p
we could go to do an unnecessary step
here uh of writing this like uh
lin solve and doing it but uh i mean
that would be ridiculous here
okay so all that note here is that t is
equal to
minus p p by pi
so the solution is nothing but minus p
by pi okay and
all that if you do for our sigma rr is
to
uh for the sigma r solution is to
substitute
this d with the d solution and
display this thing
okay
[Music]
so that's it done so that is our sigma
rr solution
you see everything is known here the p
is given to us
okay so so depending
at what radius from
the point of application okay
so depending on uh on what radius from
the point of application of the load
you want to find out the stress you keep
on increasing this r
you will be considering correspondingly
different arcs these different
semi-circular arcs like this
and you'll be obtaining the sigma rr
values there
and of course because of this this
dependence on theta you'll be having
different values
along this but because this is a
dependence through cos
theta you will have the nice
symmetricity
maintained about the x axis or
theta equal to zero axis and
all let us not forget that
we have already arrived at this
two identities okay or these two
solutions that sigma theta theta is
equal to zero
and sigma r theta is equal to zero so
together
we have actually arrived at the solution
okay
so our solution finally is
so sigma rr is equal to
minus 2 p cos theta by pi r
minus 2 p cos theta
by pi r sigma theta theta
is equal to 0 and sigma r theta
is equal to 0 so that is our entire
solution
[Music]
right done
this and as i just and as i had
mentioned at the very beginning
so this entire problem okay so this is a
relatively simple problem if you just
if you just revise through it you'll see
that uh we although we had to do a
little bit of
brain work in terms or detective work
in terms of of of navigating of
navigating our way through the solution
through some special steps but
ultimately uh
it is turning out to be quite
straightforward
okay there's a lot of cleverness
involved in the solution
but the the ultimate solution is coming
out in a very
neat and clean fashion but this neat and
clean solution
it will be the precursor to that entire
body
of conta to the entire field of content
contact mechanics
to geophysical sciences various problems
in geophysical sciences
uh soil mechanics as well as various uh
important problems in structural
engineering of
of civil engineering all right so with
this i'll end this lecture
thank you very much